[Music]
and speaking of which Joe Biden finally
announced he was going to visit fire
ravage Maui After ignoring reporters
questions on it just days ago while on
vacation in Delaware now I want to
quickly remind you all about something
Senator Ted Cruz flew to Cancun during a
winter storm that left much of his State
without power or water he quickly
realized that that was a mistake and he
came back but it was a days long news
cycle and he's still hearing about it
and Biden's dismissal of an unfolding
tragedy in Hawaii barely a blip for of
course the Trump obsessed media now
here's what they're missing
there are now reports that the death
toll will not just rise in Maui but will
tragically include scores of children
who were kept home because power outages
for schools to close joining us now
Tulsa gabbard former Hawaii
congresswoman and a Fox News contributor
um tells you just got back from Maui
please tell us what you saw there this
is so heartbreaking for all Americans to
see
yeah Laura it's it's difficult to put
into words uh this tragic loss that
continues to grow that we're continuing
uh to see and experience and feel uh
every time there are more and more uh
names and and numbers of our friends and
Neighbors in Lahaina who have perished
because of this Wildfire now there's
still over a thousand people who are
missing there's still the vast majority
of that area of Devastation that needs
to be gone through by those who are that
are that are conducting this recovery
operation but I also want to speak to
the many many families who live in the
community surrounding Lahaina just north
of that historic town who are continuing
to struggle many of them did not have
power for days they were told the water
was contaminated having to shower and
bathe their children with bottled water
cut off from communication the cell
phone towers were down they had no Wi-Fi
or internet connectivity these are
people who stood up in the midst of this
tragedy and and did everything they
could to help each other the sad part is
we are eight days past this wildfire and
I'm in constant touch with these
community members and leaders they are
still not seeing response from the
county the state the federal government
to be able to go out and help them the
community support hubs that they have
are a hundred percent community-led
volunteer Supply collections conducting
all of these coordinations on their own
they feel like the government doesn't
care about them and and that's a
horrible horrible disservice to people
who have gone through uh a kind of loss
that that we can't even imagine no I
mean we have a lot of commitments around
the globe and we're not getting into
politics here but you know we do spend
billions and billions of dollars and
allocate it to you know other countries
issues and problems and this is when we
realize we you have to you know put your
own oxygen mask on first before you can
really help others and these people need
help they need help now not not you know
a week from now
that's exactly right when you think
about you know there's a mom a woman
named Andrea he's a mom a stay-at-home
mom raising her kids she has stepped up
and spent every day and night trying to
be a coordinator to get the supplies
that volunteers are trying to bring in
and oftentimes having to circumvent
blockades put in place by the county
just to get those supplies to them to
get them to where they need not only are
they not getting the support that they
need but oftentimes they have been
getting blocked from being able to
receive the support from their friends
uh and neighbors uh this is a this is a
crisis that is continuing on it is not
at all lost on the people of West Maui
when they're told that FEMA is going to
give those impacted a one-time 700
dollar payment and as they look at the
news they're seeing tens of more
millions of dollars being sent to
Ukraine some of them said hey maybe if
we just change the name of maui to
Ukraine maybe then they'll pay attention
to us yeah tell see and I know all the
breaking news tonight about the
background of the chief emergency
response coordinator didn't have a lot
of experience in these types of
situations the sirens apparently weren't
working as they should have for this
type of event fire event and all of this
will get to the bottom of but Tulsi
thank you thank you for your report hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else